what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video today I want to
discuss some of the things that we seen
in the preview teaser for episode 2 and
a few other things from the premiere
that may give us some clues as to what
we may see this Sunday let's start off
with Daenerys Targaryen way she has
Tyrion shall we begin
Daenerys and Tyrion will hold their own
little small council meeting with Varys
--mess and a grey worm Theon Yara
olaria and even Lady Olenna is there too
it's kind of hard to see her sitting
there in a chair but you can kind of
make out her hat and if you've been
staying up to date with all my videos
then you should already know that this
was gonna happen an article came out
about a month ago that said this scene
with all of these exact characters was
going to take place in the teaser you
can hear your say we have an army a
fleet and three dragons we should hit
King's Landing now and this made me very
excited because there could be another
battle on the Blackwater Bay Euron's
fleet is going to be leaving the base so
he can go get Circe's gift as Daenerys
forces could be entering the bay causing
an all-out war Tyrion is going to advise
them to attack Casterly Rock first
because not only will it cut off the
Lannister secondary forces but it's also
going to leave sir see what nowhere to
run once they do strike King's Landing
we've already seen a ton of evidence of
this in the trailers grey worm is going
to enter Casterly Rock through a secret
entrance and then he's gonna let the
rest of the unsullied in and storm the
castle but I'm not exactly sure if
you're a Theon and the sand snakes are
gonna go there to Daenerys and Tyrion
might send them somewhere else but on
their way there they're gonna get
attacked by your own Greyjoy we've got a
quick glimpse of this in the episode -
teaser also it looks like one of the
sand snakes is in the middle of a fight
right here it appears to be tyene saying
most likely fighting one of Euron's men
during the attack
I think Euron is going to wipe out your
as fleet and take some of them prisoner
the sand snakes especially and this is
going to be his gift to Cersei if you
remember back in season five glorious
and poison Circe's daughter Marcella
right before Jaime was able to take her
back home
Cersei will want revenge for this and
Euron will attack the Greyjoy and
Martell
and take them both out then take some of
them back to Cersei as his gift which is
gonna help him form that alliance
between him and Cersei Lady Olenna will
probably go back home to Highgarden and
most likely provide resources for
Daenerys and her army because
Dragonstone doesn't produce any food
itself and Daenerys has a lot of mouths
to feed and you don't want the Dothraki
going hungry and going out and getting
things on their own but we all know
Jaime Lannister's could probably get
word that Lady Olenna is dead and the
Lannisters are responsible for it and
this is going to force Daenerys to act
herself as Jaime and his forces marched
back from Highgarden Daenerys and the
Dothraki will ambush them in the open
field where the Dothraki are at their
best Daenerys will lose a lot of men in
this battle but this along with taking
Casterly Rock is going to [ __ ] the
Lannister army and that will put
Daenerys one step closer to knocking
Cersei off the Iron Throne
but let's go to another scene from the
episode two teaser which is of Arya
Stark who has a surprised look on her
face this very well may be when the wolf
shows its teeth in the trailer some
people have said this is named area but
I disagree Nymeria will more than likely
be a lot larger than this but don't
worry because Nymeria will be close by
once arya gets back on the road heading
to King's Landing she will be startled
by this wolf that comes out at her but
this wolf will not end up attacking Arya
because I believe this is one of the
Wolves from Nymeria SPAC this wolf will
growl and show its teeth to Arya
but I think Nymeria will come out of
nowhere and instantly reconnect with
Arya making this wolf stand down and
back off when arya and i'm area reunite
it's going to be absolutely amazing the
dire wolves are like a reflection of the
stark children and ever since Arya had
to run Nymeria off leaving her lost in
the woods Arya has been lost in a sense
as well when rere connects what Nymeria
this may cause her to change course and
decide not to go to King's Landing
Nymeria might remind Arya of home and
family and being together as a pack
instead of a lone wolf making Aria
decide to go home herself and reconnect
with her own pack the rest of the stark
children and speaking of home and stark
children let's go to Winterfell next
in the episode two teaser we get another
scene in the Hall of Winterfell where
Yan Royce tells everyone that a
Targaryen can't be trusted
which is kind of ironic since they are
all putting their trust in Jon Snow as
their King and he has the blood of the
Dragon in his veins as well but no one
up north knows that just yet
except for Bryan and maybe Meera and her
father and maybe Littlefinger and maybe
Varys
but since Yan Roy said this the word is
spreading that Daenerys has arrived in
Westeros Daenerys may have even sent
Ravens el telling everyone that she is
here and she has plans of rolling the
Seven Kingdoms what she says she was
born to do although people hate Cersei
I'm not so sure everyone's going to be
open to having another Targaryen rule
either especially since her father was
the Mad King so she's gonna make sure to
spread propaganda about Daenerys as well
you can hear Cersei and this teaser
mentioned her being the daughter of the
Mad King trying to make people think
that she will be just as crazy as her
father which is kind of ironic also
because Cersei is [ __ ] crazy right
now but she's gonna spin it into her
favor however she sees fit John will
probably receive word from Daenerys and
he's going to receive word from Samwell
Tarly also after Sam found out where the
dragon glass was on Dragonstone he wrote
a letter to John right away
now stain has already told Sam he could
get up sitting in there but now Sam
knows exactly where to find it but you'd
think Davos would know something about
this also John just gave a speech in the
first episode saying that he needed all
the maesters to dig through the records
to find out more information about
dragonglass all the time Davos spent
there with Stannis I'm surprised he
doesn't know about it too and tells John
but either way it really doesn't matter
because John is gonna go down there
anyway we can see the men getting ready
to leave Winterfell in the teaser but
before John Lee's Winterfell he's gonna
go down into the crypts to pay his
respects and visit his family before he
leaves we've seen a few glimpses of John
down here in the trailers and promos it
looks like John and Littlefinger are
standing at Lee on a statue but they're
actually standing at Ned's I think Ned's
tomb should be next to Liana's rate
where John is standing and looking at we
know something is going to happen down
here that causes John to grab
Littlefinger by his throat and slam him
against the wall just like Ned did the
little finger back in
first season there are a few different
things that Littlefinger may say to John
that's gonna cause this Littlefinger
might say something about Ned or
Littlefinger could say something about
Sansa or he could even say something
about the way John has been ruling the
north whatever he says is gonna piss
John off which is gonna put Littlefinger
one step closer to being executed in
Winterfell after this happens and John
leaves for Dragonstone
this will cause Littlefinger to plant
even more seeds of doubt and Songz's
head about John we can only hope sunset
continues to ignore Littlefinger's
[ __ ] and lies the next time we see
the hound and a Brotherhood without
banners I think they're gonna background
or else Jonah's gonna lose most of his
companions during this trip when we see
Sam again he's probably gonna have some
of the more eager to help Jorah it will
be interesting to see what Sam does to
prevent the greyscale from spreading any
further I'm gonna mention a spoiler real
quick so if you don't want to know just
turn down the volume for about 30
seconds the plot league said Sam's gonna
use dragon class to cure his greyscale
I'm not really sure how that's gonna
cure it but it will be interesting to
see it does appear that one of the pages
Sam was reading mentions dragon class in
the word cure so it might be right I
think we can expect a little bit of a
faster pace in the next episode now that
we touched base with each character they
all seemed to have a plan moving forward
that we should see take action at least
I'm hoping but I'm gonna end the video
right here there wasn't a whole lot to
go on based off the teaser for episode 2
we should see the battle on the seed
next episode with Joran so I'm very
excited for that it should be pretty
damn intense but comment down below with
your thoughts and questions what do you
think happens in the next episode what
would you like to see in the next
episode let me know and leave some
questions down below also about what
we've seen in the first episode and in
this teaser I may do a Q&A video this
week also and as always thanks for
stopping by and watching the video I
want to thank my patreon supporters and
all my new patreon supporters also I'm
actually working on a new thank-you card
to add to each video that should be
ready by the next time I drop a video
just to show my appreciation for all the
love you guys showed me
but anyways have a good day everyone and
I'll see you down in the comment section
bye
you